il n'y a aucune raison valable de nous
cacher secret depuis trois décennies et
gouvernement nous manque sur les ovnis
depuis 50 ans d'accord cette lumière
quelque chose comme ça en fait c'est un
seul objet qu'est ce que c'est que
j'espère traitement par un avion tu fais
quoi dans ma vie
[Musique]
les avions de l'armée de l'air peut pas
j'espère que ce sont les nôtres en tout
cas
tout ça pour vous montrez que vous
prenez cette histoire un peu trop au
sérieux
les maires de phoenix sont partis au sud
et c'est là que nous devons aller que
m'en vais y aller quoi il est 6 heures
du matin ça va être énorme
on n'a rien voir là-haut criardes
c'est quoi ça ashley on va sortir de là
qu'est ce qui vient de se passer et mais
ça va
il manque encore
roquet 4 hectare juste voiture maria
clijsters fait
remontez la guerre du kippour
tu fais pas ma vie